Glenn Greenwald has long reported on the
political abuses of the legal system he
is the host of system update on Rumble
and our friend he joins us tonight Glenn
you would think somebody would say look
I don't like Trump
but this is doing grave damage to
institutions we're going to need two
years from now and for the next hundred
years but not one person that we can
find has said that
I heard you in your prior segment saying
words people like Karl Rove and George
Bush and the people who leicesterized I
think people like Victoria Newland
demonstrate that theater behind this
whole Republican versus Democratic War
yes this is the key to the whole thing
which is that they are determined not to
criminalize conservatism or the
Republican Party they're fine with
people like Jeb Bush or John McCain or
Mitt Romney or Nikki Haley or Lindsey
Graham or whoever they're determined to
criminalize Donald Trump in his movement
because the only time Victoria Newman
wasn't in government she was work for
Clinton then she worked for decaney then
she worked for Obama now she worked for
Biden was When Donald Trump was elected
president so that's the only way you get
these people out of government and
that's why they're single-mindedly
determined to criminalize not their
Republican party but Donald Trump and
his movement and that's what we saw
yesterday with his indictment and today
with this person who's now going to
prison because of anti-hillary Clinton
memes he posted on Twitter
the problem is in organizing the system
that way they cut out the majority of
the population or the majority of
American voters of either party in favor
for example of going to war with
nuclear-armed Russia and China I don't
think there's any evidence the majority
is in favor of that do you
no or for example keeping troops in
Syria which I would bet you barely
anybody even knows that the United
States is doing let alone wants to and
yet Matt Gates had a resolution to
withdraw all troops in Syria saying we
shouldn't be spending money on that we
should be spending money here at home
and the Republicans and Democrats joined
together The Establishment links to say
no we want to keep Gillette Joe Biden
keep troops to Syria it's the
establishment wings of both parties that
are the real enemy and they're the ones
who rule no matter where what you go and
do at the voting booth Donald Trump was
the only one who could disrupt it and
that's why they want to criminalize that
movement it's exactly right I mean if
you were just to write out the crimes of
Donald Trump
being obnoxious okay versus the crime
Satoria Newlin destroying the West
you know one list should be longer than
the other but who's getting indicted
Glenn Greenwell thank you so much I
appreciate that very much subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight